[Music]
we hope you're up-to-date on all your
pretty little liar secrets because today
we're spoiling some of the major
differences between the books and the
show stay tuned to see how number one
caught everyone by surprise don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to the things warning this
video contains major spoilers now let's
check out the 20 differences between
Pretty Little Liars books and TV show no
Caleb did you know that caleb is never
mentioned in the Pretty Little Liars
books whatever he's involved with in the
show never actually happened in the
books well apart from the scene in the
first book where the Montgomery family
drive to their old house and Mike points
out and says that there's Caleb's house
fans suspect that this probably wasn't
the same Caleb but knowing what we know
now it's pretty weird that this is a
coincidence
so far caleb has never appeared in the
books so it's safe to assume that he'll
never be featured which also means all
your favorite Caleb moments never even
happened in the books
no Ezria well sort of as Rhea gets a
mixed response from Pretty Little Liars
fans but those that aren't so fond of
this teacher-student relationship should
know that as Rhea
isn't so heavily featured in the books
in fact their story is quite short
it starts similarly as the show they
meet at the bar and hit it off for the
affair is short-lived as a tips off the
police who come and arrest
Ezra but the school decides not to press
charges
Ezra then leaves for Pennsylvania and
isn't seen until the tenth book where he
comes back and makes things even worse
Aria and Noel Kahn so it's because as
Ria's relationship is so short-lived in
the books the story is mostly focused on
Aria and nocon in the TV show we see the
rich boy Knoll date Mona and break up
with Aria after he discovers she's
dating Ezra Knowles quite the Casanova
in the books and is seen kissing plenty
of girls including Ellison who tricked
him to make Aria leave him it's all very
complicated and the couple goes through
several breakups in the books
coincidentally Knoll and Ezra end up
hooking up with the same students how
bizarre is that bye Mona okay this one
is a bit gruesome and
huge spoiler alert if you haven't read
the books if you have a love/hate
relationship with Mona you might want to
read the books because her story is just
a little bit different than the show in
the books after Spencer realizes who
Mona really is and why Hanna had a car
accident she confronts her but the
situation doesn't end that well for Mona
they fight and Spencer pushes Mona down
a cliff and that's it for Mona's part of
the story well at least in the books
because we all know how mutters story
ended up in the TV show
Toby ends his life Toby's story is
largely different in the books than it
is from the TV show in the series he has
a somewhat happy ending well until he
gets hit by a car and breaks his leg we
also know that at some point he tries to
deal with his mom's passing which makes
him go just a bit crazy but in the books
Emily thinks Toby's the one responsible
for what happened to Alison while Toby
thought she knew what happened to Jenna
Emily doesn't listen to him and the next
morning his body is found behind Emily's
house
Toby overdosed on pills and passed away
r.i.p Jenna
Jenna's character was the one that was
completely different in the books sure
she was messed up in her own way for
what she did to Toby in the series you
have to admire her no BS attitude in the
TV show people attempted to end her life
twice with no success but in the books
Aria realizes that Jenna knows who the
second day is by the time she finds her
to confront her on what she knows
Jenna's body is found stuffed in a ditch
and that's the end for Jana Cavanaugh
well at least in the books
Charlotte is Courtney who is Alison
don't worry we'll explain Charlotte was
a huge character in both versions of
Pretty Little Liars but her story in the
books is slightly different in the books
Charlotte is Courtney Courtney is
Alison's twin sister in the books the
two used to love to pretend they were
each other the two don't really have a
good relationship and since we all know
that Alison is crazy and was sent to a
psychiatric hospital you can guess what
happened when Alison made people think
she was actually Courtney seriously this
story is all kinds of twisted and we
absolutely love it know five years jump
at the end of season six fans of the
show got to see a special
behind-the-scenes episode that showed
what the characters would be doing five
years from now Caleb and Hanna aren't
dating
Radley did not become a hotel Aria does
not work with Ezra and so on and so if
you weren't particularly thrilled by
looking into the character's future you
might want to read
because that actually never happened
even better some of the characters don't
even exist and some were not even alive
by this time although Ezra is actually
just as messed up in the books as this
future predicted Emily gets pregnant
Emily's coming-out story in Pretty
Little Liars is extremely important and
it stays that way in the books but guess
what Paige isn't even a character in the
books and all the events that involve
Paige and Emily don't really exist
instead Emily Falls for Maya and their
relationship is one of the most
important ones in the books but that's
not all in the ninth book it's revealed
that she's also pregnant in the books
Emily tries to hide her pregnancy from
her Christian parents and ends up giving
her baby girl away to the couple that
wanted to adopt her her baby's name is
violet the characters themselves the
characters from the books look a lot
different than the one you might know on
the show out of all of them Aria is the
one that looks most like her TV show
version but even then Aria has blue eyes
in the books and hazel eyes on the show
meanwhile emily has strawberry blonde
hair in the books
Hanna's hair is brown and Spencer's is
blonde Emily's character is also largely
different in the books as she's much
more shy and relatable and none of the
main characters actually have the same
birthday as they do in the books Hanna's
eating disorder on the TV show Hanna
confesses her eating disorder at school
after she receives a text from a but in
the books her eating disorder is
revealed in a slightly different way
we know that Spencer is the one that
gets locked up in a mental institution
on the actual show but in the books
things take a different turn Hanna is
the one that gets set to a clinic
because of her eating disorder which is
a lot worse than what we see on the show
this also happens around the time when a
taunts her from her eating disorder and
Mona gets thrown off a cliff
Bobi since Toby turns out to be a pretty
horrible character in the books it's
safe to say he didn't have such a
memorable role which also means that
there was no SPO B aka the relationship
between Spencer and Toby Toby does end
up going to a dance with Emily at some
point but it never becomes one of the
main storylines as he ends up having a
terrible fate so early in the books so
if you're looking for steamy SPO B
scenes in the books you'll just have to
re-watch the actual show because that's
the only way you'll be able to enjoy
them no rest for the wicked
seriously the books are so much more
intense than the
TV show the drama never stops there are
far more secrets and scandals and some
of them are so well written
you don't even figure them out until a
few chapters later if you like the messy
drama that comes with this show but you
want to see more of it you absolutely
should read the books count just how
many times someone loses their life
someone gets in a fight and end the
other glorious scandals these characters
seem to act out so well there really is
no rest for the wicked and Pretty Little
Liars
Emily's sexuality we already mentioned
that Emily got pregnant in the books
which also means her sexuality is
presented in a slightly different way on
the TV show emily is primarily a gay
character and a romances with men just
aren't seen which we're all thankful for
because that's one of the many things we
love about this show but in the actual
books
Emily's character is bisexual and can be
seen in relationships with men and women
Emily's relationships are also in focus
throughout all books while her
character's sexuality isn't as
highlighted in the final season and we
don't even hear much about her romances
as other relationships are put in focus
the n80 Club we all love the secrets in
Pretty Little Liars TV show so naturally
we were all there for the secret filming
Club created by Jason Ian and Garrett
but filming teenage girls in their
bedrooms is just so creepy not even the
books wanted to take this on yep that's
right but an 80 club does not exist in
the books and there's no plot that would
revolve around the club in fact Garrett
doesn't even exist in the books to be
fair it's probably for the better
because we can barely keep up with the
scandals from the books as if characters
that don't exist we all have our
favorite side or even main characters on
Pretty Little Liars and it's hard to
believe a story without them we already
said that Caleb and Paige don't exist in
the books but there are far more
characters you will never see they
include Shana Charles Bethany Sarah and
Mary but there are also book characters
that don't appear on the show such as
kelsey amelia isaac courtney de
dilaurentis's Mick and Tabitha in fact
at some point Emily had a crush on
Kelsey
but we cast her character wasn't worth
highlighting on the TV show as Emily had
Paige and that's all we need Ali is a
twin
so we already briefly mentioned this but
let's talk about it more because the
fact that Ali has a twin changes the
entire storyline which is also why you
don't see the character courtney de
dilaurentis's on the actual show allison
is a major character in the TV show but
imagine just how twisted it would all
look if you'd see her have a live twin
with whom she'd frequently get in
trouble and you'd never know whether it
was Courtney or Allison on screen
actually never mind we can see how that
would clearly be too confusing for this
already mysterious show Darrin wildin
Darrin is a completely different
character in the book than he is on the
show he's a detective in both situations
but the portrayal of his character is
vastly different in the books he's
actually done some pre shady things
himself while on the TV show he's shown
as pretty much the good guy one of the
big differences also involves his dating
life in the books
Darrin dates Melissa who ends up
pregnant with his kid but we all know
that Darrin doesn't even make it out on
the show take that CC you can't get them
all Mike and Knoll if you're not a fan
of these side characters on the show
this won't mean much but if you are you
should definitely check out the books
because Mike and NOLA actually play a
lot more important parts in the plot
he has a strange reason for getting back
with Hanna in the books in the books
NOLA saria's boyfriend from much longer
than he was on the show in fact they
look totally adorable trust us by the
time you finish the books you'll totally
be shipping this adorable couple oh and
also Knoll ends up being alive in the
books Ali is a when Pretty Little Liars
first came out a lot of people thought
they knew exactly who a was because they
read the books because in the book
version Alison is clearly a she even
goes to jail because of it but in the TV
show Alison only appears to be a in the
show she goes to jail for what happened
to Mona
but it's later discovered that she was
only set up by the actual a and Mona
herself so if you thought you knew who a
was when you read the books this show
probably pulled off one of the best
surprises on you ever have you seen
Pretty Little Liars what's your favorite
moment from the entire show let us know
in the comments and that's all for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]